but where do you stand on elon's effect
on bitcoin and cryptocurrency in general
these days
I believe that Bitcoin is a massive
breakthrough for the human race that
will cure half the problems in the world
and generate hundreds of trillions of
dollars of economic value to the
civilization and I believe that um it's
at an early stage where many people
don't understand it and they're afraid
of it and there's fud and there's
uncertainty there's doubt there's fear
and there's a very noisy crypto world
and there's 15 000 other cryptos that
are are seeking relevance
and I think most of the fud
is actually fueled by the other crypto
entrepreneurs so the environmental flood
and the other types of of uncertainty
that's around Bitcoin generally they're
not coming from legitimate
environmentalists they don't come from
legitimate uh critics they actually are
guerrilla marketing campaigns that are
being financed and fueled by other
crypto entrepreneurs
because they have an interest in doing
so
so if I look at the constructive path
forward
first I think it'd be very constructive
for corporations to embrace Bitcoin
and and build applications on top of it
you don't you don't need to fix it
there's nothing wrong with it right like
when you put it on a layer two and a
layer three it moves a billion times a
second at the speed of light so every
beautiful coal defy application every
crypto application everything you could
imagine you might want to do you can do
with a legitimate company and a
legitimate website or mobile application
sitting on top of Bitcoin or lightning
if you want to
so I think that um to the extent that
people do that that's going to be better
for the world
if you consider what holds people back I
think it's just misperceptions about
what Bitcoin is so I'm a big fan of just
uh educating people if we're if you're
not if you're not going to commercialize
it then just educate people on what it
is so for example bitcoin's the most
efficient
use of energy in the world by far right
most people don't they don't necessarily
perceive that or realize that but if you
were to take any metric energy intensity
you put like two billion dollars worth
of electricity in the network every year
and it's worth 850 billion dollars there
is no industry in the real world right
that that is that energy efficient not
only that energy efficient it's also the
most sustainable industry we just we do
surveys 58 of Bitcoin mining energy is
sustainable so there's a very uh good
story in fact every other industry
Planes Trains automobiles construction
food medicine everything else
it's less clean less efficient
so so the basic debate I would like to I
wouldn't say there is a debate I would
just say that to the extent that the
Bitcoin Community had any issue with
Elon it was just you know the just this
environmental
you know uncertainty that he fueled in a
couple of his tweets right
uh which I think just is very
distracting
but that was one of them but I think
it's like the Bitcoin Maximus but
generally the crypto Community what you
call the the crypto entrepreneurs are
you know it's also they're using it
first I mean for investment for
speculation and therefore get very
passionate about people's kind of uh uh
celebrities including you like famous
people right
um saying positive stuff about any one
particular
crypto
thing a thing you can buy in coinbase
and so
um they might be unhappy with Elon Musk
that he's promoting Bitcoin and then not
and then promoting Dogecoin than not and
this kind of
um
that there's so much emotion tied up in
the communication on this topic
and that's I think that's where a lot of
the look I don't have I don't have a
criticism of Elon Musk he's free to do
whatever he wishes to do it's his life
in fact Elon Musk is the you know the
second largest supporter of Bitcoin in
the world so I think that the Bitcoin
Community tends to eat its own quite a
bit Yeah it tends to be very
uh very self-critical and instead of
saying
well Elon is more supportive of Bitcoin
than the other 10 000 people in the
world you know with serious amounts of
money they like they focus upon you know
yeah this is strange eating your own is
just um that's right I mean I think he
he's free to do what he wants to do like
and I I think he's done a lot of good
for Bitcoin and and putting it on the
balance sheet of Tesla and holding it
and I think that sent a very powerful
message